Uh, let's go to, um, why don't we go to our
caller from the five one, two area code.
Who's calling today from five one two.
Yes.
Is this me?
Yes it is.
Who's this?
This is Schuyler from us.
And nice to talk to you David.
Likewise.
Um, I had two options for you.
What'd you like a fun and silly question or
a more serious question.
Give me the fun and silly first.
Okay.
Well, you rarely talk about sports being that
you're a political commentator, but when you
do, you always, how much you have Argentina
football and especially Lionelle MSCI.
Uh, would you, how do you feel about people
grown, grown adults specifically who wears
sports jerseys?
Listen, the sports Jersey.
So are you talking about on game day or like
to work?
Um, either way.
I mean, it makes no difference to me as long
as you're not being paid to actually do the
sport for the Jersey.
Right?
So, listen here, here's my view.
I actually, the Jersey thing, I don't really
care about that much.
But here, here's something I have been thinking
about lately.
I used to watch every red Sox game.
I would watch every Celtics game.
I would watch every Patriots game.
You know, I was really a fan and I couldn't
imagine when I was 16, 17, 18, even 22, I
couldn't imagine a time where that wouldn't
be a huge part of my life.
And then as I continued to, um, uh, develop
in my career and it to start valuing certain
other things, including relationships and
paying more attention to, uh, you know, the
political world and valuing, spending more
time reading and all of these things.
Uh, it's, it's actually hard to fit in following
the teams that I like nearly as much as I
did at one point.
But more interestingly, there was a period
where I felt bad about it, but now I actually
see, you know, 55 year olds who are, like
you're saying, wearing the Jersey all the
time, watching every game going crazy, acting,
acting out in many ways.
And I don't totally get it.
It does strike me as a little bit weird because
it's just like, I, I, it's hard for me, I
guess given everything that's going on in
the world and everything that one's focus
can be on.
I'm a casual fan and I get being a casual
fan for life, but some of the extreme fandom,
particularly in middle age does strike me
as a little bit weird.
I do admit that.
Okay.
I was just curious.
Uh, also would you, uh, like a Sergio Aguayo
Jersey if I sent one to you?
No, I don't need any jerseys, so please keep
all of the Jersey.
I, I am all good with jerseys.
I have more than enough jerseys for, uh, for,
for what?
For my life right now, but I do appreciate
it.
Yes sir.
David, thank you so much.
You have a great day.
All right, great to hear from you.
I appreciate it.
On that note, let's go to a break.
I'm sorry I couldn't get to everyone.
I never can, but I hope to talk to many of
you folks again, next time we take calls,
quick break back after this